when you put your authentic self out
there
hopefully people respond to like oh
that's good but the second you start
creating to impress them to get their
validation to get their view
everybody's different you're not for
everybody so then you're gonna get
insecure like
it didn't work like i was trying to be
what they wanted me to be and it didn't
work
well nobody wants you to be they want
you to be you
like show up and be you when i first
started stand up i was trying to pretend
i was super mexican
and i would all my early jokes when i
talk about my mom my dad they have an
accent and they're very like i mean you
threw the ball over there and like all
this stuff
my mom does not speak spanish at all
my dad does not speak spanish i'm fourth
generation mexican
and it wasn't until i started like
owning that i still have people that
their favorite jokes
of mine is the one where um it's one of
my first jokes
and i'm talking about my mom and dad and
their very spanish accent and
how i spank everybody's kids because
that's how mexican people do it and
i still have people are like oh my god
that's like my favorite joke and i was
like wow that's like my first one when i
wasn't even being true to myself but
thank you i'm glad you responded to it
and liked it
because i knew it was funny it made
people laugh it just wasn't
me but when i started owning me
and being just me not who i thought they
wanted me to be but owning
i don't speak spanish let me write a
joke about how i don't speak spanish
instead of pretending
that i speak spanish and hope they don't
catch me so when i started owning that
and being true to who i am people
respond to authenticity people respond
to that
truth and so that's when i really
started to see like
more growth oh how do you tap into that
authenticity i mean
let's think about who are you what makes
you
happy what makes you sad what what is
your
trauma from childhood do you have any um
what is the thing that gives you anxiety
do you get anxiety
what is your quirk what is the thing
like eminem yourself
like from eight mile where he comes into
the battle
and he just disses himself
before the other guy can he's like yeah
i'm this i'm poor i'm this all these
things
and what's that guy gonna say you don't
have anything to say now you just
clowned yourself
so it's like think about what are all
the things about you that
self-deprecating
not in a way where it's like everybody
not is like oh bummer should we give
this guy some antidepressant pills like
he really needs some help like
not necessarily in that way but finding
the joy
in making fun of yourself before someone
else can like
let me just be vulnerable and authentic
like i'm bow legged
that's not real sexy like i'm insecure
about my bow legs like when i put my
feet together look they do this
and then i show everybody like so if
somebody's in the audience looking like
oh she's super bowl
again and then i go you guys i'm bowling
like look what happens with my legs like
i look like a camel
and like all these things and it's like
oh my god she does look like a camel
and whatever it is it's like i'm being
authentic to
who i am because i actually am insecure
about my bow legs like if i wasn't
insecure about it didn't care then i
won't pretend to be insecure about it
but i actually am so let me just be
honest about that
i'm insecure that i don't speak i'm
embarrassed that i don't speak spanish
everybody stop looking at me i'm
embarrassed
like that i've done that on stage before
because that's my actual feelings like
i'm embarrassed that i don't speak
spanish and everybody's looking at me
and they're judging me stop judging me
everybody
and that's just being authentic that's
just being what i actually think can
feel
yeah that's what ron functions told us
on here was he really found a
breakthrough when he started talking
about
what embarrassed him that's good
yeah so just being willing to tap into
that
i guess it gets easier the more you do
it i would imagine but it's first
setting the intention to write about
embarrassing things
that's good that's a good note for even
me writing more material like
hey hop breathaverse thank you for
watching and if you want to help us
create more
content like this click the join patreon
button
and if you want to help more people find
these awesome videos
click watch more videos